Was no thirty to 1932 and he so might
want you chaps in the photo. And the way
the better i said i mean i love all these
and that doesn't matter. I want you among
the heads of department i want the men
represented to so my my my we are in the
photo and we got in the photo and these
are you come across to try and have
a ride across the prime with us and we had
the privilege of being on that train and
went across the first train and went
across arbour bridge because they read or
after their lunch and we had to come back
to work. When he got on well with but
redfield and with the engineers and whatever.
What about the foreman and going out
in the public works. Well guess any on
that when we came back from the walk
which we went mad
a couple of beers before we came back to
celebrate it. And the rope was there as
you said well you fellows wait. I think we
have been across the bridge with. These
and i think you've done enough for the day
that i think you better go out so we let
us go out that day but he
was a very trying to leave
a low but some of the supervisors
were very nasty men.
And then when one chap was very nasty
things to say about a man but. Now
a lot of the gate was looking
for work and he promised to ask
a couple of them they can sleep
with their wives and give them
a job. And that really happened. I know
chapter that that happened. They tell me
about it. So i know that was right
as a very sad thing of being
a man that they were like that
and was very said i think
a mandate that except that they get
a job that really happened and that
time. It certainly was. Yeah it was so
but. We were i think where we are
happy it was never any arguments or
just friends and among men
and it was unionism with
a very loud then and i was still in the
union the captain the union. We never ever
saw anybody from the young. That the b w
o you or the carpenters that was the
amalgamated trappers union at that time. I've
been in the young and since 1921. First in
the progressive and then the amalgamated
gardeners and then during the war
years they joined up in the b.w.
I took over and still represent
the carpenters and i mean they
represent all capital
communist inspired. With
a good union by comparison to
the other one. But there was
a period where i suppose
their organization was
a very good. They. Sort of
the benefit of the work.
There is a very
a growing grew gap and it became more
prevalent there were more chapters about
a building was more strong.
The sydney started to build
a lot of places on the grows naturally and
that produced more cars which makes the
young and strong. Tell me something. If
you or your biography with when were you
born. Mr.
Milligan road born on the journey for
the november 1899 and makes me a
b to know. My paper
a french australian born out here where but
were you born. Maybe the united states
it will operate. And where did you
grow up and willem alluded to you in school
in the sydney harbour and down darling
harbour. I can remember there's i can
remember sydney before we had trams we had
was buses member is about 9am for i lived
in darling harbour before the markets
was built when the old paddy's markets was
going as the capital. Yet and now that's
the original burma market and then i saw
the trams come on. And i've seen the trams
you know i moved from the darling harbour
section down the well i'm eleven hours
that all my parents died
in 1914. After that or
a couple of years after i went to the world.
When did you first up were. No i mean
i'm only i was fourteen or
thirteen and that when i go. I had
a do there because we were pretty
hard up and we made money so i got
a job. My first job was that
they'd buy but wait. In
a chemist. And when you get your
indentures is the tough to know that
it's another's doria. And though when i
came back from the same job in the first
war. Well let's let's cover the first well
when you went to the war. What did you do
there. Will you then when you enter the
war. Well i noticed and seventeen that
i'd been in the cadets in the compulsory
training and i let and i was very keen
soldiering and they'd make me go up and ceos
girl now becoming ceo. I took on by
an authority and physical culture as
a project and they kept me there for
a while and i never got away.
Well either in 1918 and i
get in england for
a while and the world was nearly finished
runner i went over there. It was just
about ready to go got over there and i
got no money. So i missed the war. I
didn't see much of it. I never saw any
battles or anything. I just was over there
and i was
a lot of the seventeen but chalion don't
know me but still i was over there.
Married. It was my fault. And when you got
back. Many of them managed to get your
indentures
a different and well when we came
home in 1919 in the meantime i had
learnt motor mechanic work in england and
i like being and i got and then from the
vocational training. So the
repatriation department and i went
a technical trail went there for
nine months and went out as
a thirty per cent carbon day but instead
of that i realised and i don't believe me
. Tried like this and i stayed
a i asked for an extension and i stayed
there for. Two years at the technical
trolley different parts of it
and i lived on two guineas
a week for two years to learn my
trade and i was only there five days
a week of the tech and i
reckon that was better than
a and then apprenticeship because you had
trained men looking out you know all the
time and i stayed there for two years
and i came out as a trust myself as
a voter ids and that's that's the story.
If you and then you've got on the average
no you got other jobs first but i was worked
on different types of jobs everywhere
and sydney and them days you just went
around looking for work and you're going to
work you might be fixing it. That's putting
doors windows and things like that
finishing off and i'd do a roofing
job. And i'd get a country job and
a big factory job. I know i worked
on gold for my watch big fire job in
a month for about seven or eight months and
i'd done jobs in the country. But first
rebuild
a lot of power couple of places up there
and then gradually i weary of debate out
doing jobs everywhere because you in the
building trade you don't stay in one place
it just may have
a bad. Doing that you get experience by
dependent doing different types of work
place i'm living here i built
1928 this house. Still is
as good as new this last room we're
in our build thirty years ago but
i like my work. You know i'm very keen on
carpentry and. I even made my i'm for an
extra bedrooms wait in queensland
to get my daughter from forty five
shillings are hundred feet so far
in them days by the hour. And
that solid queensland maple
as well not the near
a they buy one boards. You
wouldn't buy that the money. Yes
. Tell me when you were on the bridge.
Remember the working conditions being harder
or easier than anywhere else. Now we just
done an ordinary day's work. We just
naturally we didn't raise or race.
And we never let a jap with
a whip overs but. I had one leading and
i can't think of his name but he lived
locally but he was a very nice
fellow and. We all just worked as
a team we just done the job properly
correctly and we used to grow up as these
these these men and calmly care for him
directly. And we done everything right and
it was never any mistakes without work. Yet
their work they were the idle light and
we up there were everything was done precision
and although we camps just don't he
working. And then being any of us broke our
back but we worked steady anyway all of
mine. Where where were you in the bridge
was opened. I was on at that time i
was. I was finished and i want
some shops underneath the
mills and find station where the tram just
around i was on that side. That's where
we built the shops enlivened by
a road and we had finished.
The station management
point station stairs and
a concrete where they've been done earlier
of course and we'd been fixed and we
were done all the fixing work and i was
one of the lucky ones that was kept on to
do the finishing work and then we
built the last very doable as i
pull the escalators down that went up to
the top now days. Now the escalators going
up to the top when the ferries were there
after the ferries that was from the
temperate temporary milton's point station
to lend street terms mansour over
a month there and when we had to pull
that down we were tired from from
the wharf which they aren't allowed to
park or you know that used to be the mills
and points more and then we we fixed
the park out. I meant tidy the park
up and put tree guards and things like that
round them. That was my last job them.
To what happened the escalators. Now they
were both down. They were just destroyed
i think sold or given away to something i
know i fell down to the top of the bottom
ones that was my last job i skidded out
of the only places i did it was like
that probably and you know it was the last
that was there. That was the last time i
was there and then you
were on the dole for
a while. Yes. Things were very very hard
after that until you start at this relief
work. Allowed ease the situation
a little bit before that you know you
just went down to them they worked about
and. You've got a ticket to
get so much groceries and
a mate. How weak and we are and we
started off getting at the intent. And i
threw a big lump of my that your half
a dozen loaves of bread didn't say kill
and so they're little they're you for the
week and
a very shame that they've got no way am
i that my bribed after that. But then
when we got the relief where we got it in
cash. I mean we could use our money as we
like tell me at that time when you when
you've got the coupons and then we had to
draw the food for it. What did you do first
say cooking for the money for the gas
or whatever and well where you just.
Look what we could do if i had
a fuel's derivatives house at the time
and we had to cook most all on the field
stivers we would now but i
don't but when i built a house
a mining twenty eight. And you know couple
of i had up in the place. But i guess
we're just managed and get
a few shillings. We're good. And
there were deprived of that and.
I was playing the place or up from the
bank the government savings bank state
savings bank. They were very good to me
though even paid my rates here. I couldn't
play anything i had no money and they don't
buy that while i have this unemployed
coupon that they wouldn't allow it to
go carry i think for two years. They
never they never i never paid anything but
pay their aup since of course. But they
were very very good. There was when they
said they were never there. Presume
a property. Jack lanning of course started
a moratorium that out that out as he did
was dropped. Ms asian going back gives
a shame that those chaps of got killed on
the bridge but no compensation because
there was no medical compensation on them
days and they just at the take it. I'm
afraid that they did get some would say
there was workers there wasn't one killed
before 1926 when the workers compensation
started. They were all killed after all
i'm wrong i thought it was after i
married jack lang deck lang was
a man that put the workers compensation
act through which which was very had
a hard very good. I know before that in
bad money trying to draw out an accident
and no these great to me leg
my arms and i never got
a pending out of it. That was that was
before compensation. Those or not. There
none of you got involved in any accidents
around you on the bridge goings on and
northern approaches. No i never had an
accident at all. I was very careful and i
was a very able and i was a
very fit and them though. Being
a young man of course i very able to do
a good day's work which we did. One last
thing do you remember any funny stories
that happened while you working over there.
Now i think that you know. You know the
only one being that of memories of me
at my mates where we were fixing on the
station in the writing room putting the
seats where building the state where
everybody said and my i might just come
to work or mine. I'm used to like these
drop romany used to eat garlic. Only merely
suffocate me was like boys and girls. I
was talking about they would go outside
work. It could i couldn't stand the smell
of some of the only thing i can say about
it. I mean yeah. The people that worked
on the. On the approaches were generally
australian born with. Ah yes you know i
don't think there was any foreigners any
of them there weren't that many out of
that time that was before the influx of
immigrants but most of them are astray
liam's i can say that now everybody
army or i think was on australian
a lot of them were out there for well for
us war diggers do that came back. You
know they one of the job. But then
i think we were just a mixed crowd
a purist railings in them days. A man
that was recognised in the tried
but you did a good hard day's
work all the time allotted hours
a day already four hours a
week and body tony hours
a week they brought it down to after but
in them days everybody worked well and
we're crunching answers like today as
a little bit different. Do you remember
what you used to do in the spare
time when you had
a little bit of money in your pocket when
you before you were married and then
after that. Well you know if i was married
i was saving up to buy this block of
land i'm on now and build my house. My
people died when i was between loreen and
fifteen. My mother and father my mother
died three months i have to my father she
was
a beast got buried genes. My father was
friends. And there were very happy family
. But or very poor because at the time
and i was i was and i was living with
my sister punchbowl which was
a scrubby place there was no houses
i think there back in 1915 that
my brother first and his wife died twelve
months after my mother and they went of
the world and 1916 the elder brother
and me we had no home at all. And
so i was always wanting
a home amount and the only way i got it. I
bet i don't scrape to my i didn't go for
much. I mean as means except fishing which
is cheap. And that was my only sports
which it is deal and i saved my
money as best i could i never drank
and i never smoked in them days
a good employer. And i didn't waste my money
because i wanted to save the money the
builders house which i did. Now it's
my home and many wouldn't buy it.
Thank you very much risk of elegant.